[Musique]
avec nous pour le panel ce soir
Sébastien Bovet Hélène buzetti et
Christian Dufour bonsoir à vous trois
bonsoir avant de commencer avec les
sujets d'aujourd'hui Christian vous
vouliez revenir sur le panel d'hier vous
aviez une mise au point à faire
porter à la défense de ma collègue
Stéphanie Gramont qui suite à la
participation au panel par une
affirmation que j'ai faite a fait
l'objet de critique très méchante entre
autres sur les réseaux sociaux de
critiques très injuste on discutait en
fait du lien entre le Parti conservateur
des rituels et les complotistes et
Stéphanie avait fait référence à une
étude en fait de la chair en prévention
de la radicalisation universitaire turbo
comme ça que c'était celui-là disait
qu'il y avait la moitié des supporters
des rituels qui étaient des complotistes
ce que j'ai dit c'est une erreur et le
pays l'occasion de me répondre et ça
déclenché beaucoup de réactions
méchantes et aujourd'hui je suis allé
vérifier et choisir que l'affirmation de
Stéphanie Gramont était juste
c'est moi qui était dans l'erreur
là-dessus c'est vrai que l'étude en
question à l'époque les sondages
montraient que 49% de l'éducateur
potentiel des rituels étaient
complotistes modérément ou convaincus je
le dis il y a deux bémols importants
c'est à une époque où le parti
conservateur était à 7 et 8% des
sondages il n'était pas 13% des sondages
et les mêmes études de la chair
prétendaient que 24 % des néo-démocrates
étaient complotistes 29% des pékistes
c'était complotiste 36 % des
conservateurs 33% des libéraux ce qui
met un bémol sur ce genre d'études-là
quant à moi je termine je vais pas faire
un débat tout seul j'ai pas de doute que
les lecteurs d'erydium n'est pas en
majorité qu'on peut aussi mais je tiens
à porter la défense de Stéphanie rameau
c'est pas juste qu'on lui reproche son
affirmation d'hier elle était juste et
c'est moi que que je me suis trompé il
faut être rigoureux faut être juste dans
la vie voilà qui est précisé merci
Christian maintenant premier sujet ce
soir décision qui est tombée cet
après-midi on est députés qui n'ont pas
prêté serment au roi ne vont pas pouvoir
siéger l'Assemblée nationale ça s'en
vient vite quelques semaines à peine on
parle quand même de 11 députés de Québec
solidaire de trois députés du Parti
québécois euh Sébastien qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de ça on a entendu Pascal
Bérubé tout à l'heure dire que son parti
à l'Est tenir debout qu'est-ce qui va se
passer c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour
le Parti québécois qui est beaucoup plus
affirmative dans sa volonté de pas
prêter serment que les gens avec
solidaire les gens qui veulent sodium
disent on verra ce qui va se passer le
29 novembre
monsieur
Bérubé en fait ce qui va se passer c'est
qu'au cours des prochains jours il va y
avoir des négociations pour la
reconnaissance des groupes
parlementaires les négociations
commencent demain est-ce que ça peut
faire partie des négociations avec les
autres parties comme monnaie d'échange
ou ainsi de suite faudra voir comment ça
se ça s'articule mais la décision du
président de l'Assemblée nationale jette
un pavé dans la mort de Québec solidaire
et du Parti québécois et moi je serai
pas étonné que par le Parti québécois
force la note le 29 novembre se présente
avec ces trois députés à l'Assemblée
nationale pour voir si en effet ils sont
expulsés de force par la Saint-Jean
d'armes comme on laisse entendre dans le
document du président de l'Assemblée
nationale imaginez le titre dans les
journaux des députés indépendantistes
qui refusent de prêter serment roi
expulsé de l'Assemblée nationale du
Québec ce serait un coût fumant
important pour le pique ce serait quand
même incroyable de voir ça à l'Assemblée
nationale Christian se sont quand même
des députés qui ont été élus par la
population qui ne pourront pas siéger
sinon et représenter leur
circonscription c'est toute une saga en
fait on peut dire que
dans le combat moi j'avais l'impression
que François Paradis le président de
l'Assemblée nationale en fait agissait
un peu tacitement selon la volonté de la
carte mais un contact très responsable
et crédible dans la machine me dit non
non il est très très indépendant c'est
sa décision comme tel donc le
gouvernement kakiste pourrait essayer de
sauver les meubles si les libéraux
étaient d'accord jusqu'où ça va nous
mener tu veux dire c'est intéressant
analyser moi une chose qui me frappe
c'est que ça amène Québec solidaire oui
le PQ c'est deux parties
indépendantistes de gauche francophone
qui se déteste normalement à travailler
un peu de concert jusqu'à à quel point
le plus grand guillemet va lui suivre
c'est aussi ça la question qu'on doit se
poser mais moi personnellement
j'espère que le gouvernement le goût
là-dessus va être un peu couleur parce
que quand même les principes en jeu là
que ça soit la fin du monde le serment
au roi je pense tous les Québécois
trouve que c'est périmé et Monsieur Lego
tellement de pouvoir il est tellement
solidement installé pour pouvoir pas
être un peu magnanime là-dedans et en
tout cas c'est sûr que dans un récent
sondage donc on voyait qu'il y avait
quand même 65% des Québécois qui
disaient que les les députés devraient
pouvoir siéger même s'ils n'ont pas
prêté serment Hélène c'est une question
qui divise à Ottawa aussi ah oui
absolument quoi que ici on a réglé la
question bah en fait les bloquistes
avaient fait leur serment mais en disant
qu'ils avaient essentiellement fait leur
Nix dans le dos et qu'il n'y croyait pas
et bien il y avait eu tout ce débat
savoir est-ce qu'un serment fait sans
sincérité vaut vraiment ce qui laisse
supposé de valoir et là on avait
peuvent-ils encore siéger le président a
rendu sa décision en se basant sur un
précédent qui était arrivé à cause de
Gilles Ducept le premier député
bloquiste élu à la Chambre des communes
qui avait lui aussi dit je vais prêter
serment mais je serais pas sincère il y
avait eu tout un débat là-dessus à
savoir si son serment donc valait
quelque chose
ici à Ottawa on n'a pas voulu ouvrir
cette question la semaine passée il y a
eu un débat sur le sujet et de manière
très politique les parties ont voté
contre cette motion et c'est ça qui est
un peu dommage c'est le fait qu'on ne
soit pas capable de trouver une issue
politique à un enjeu qui soit
essentiellement politique et non pas
juridique je pense pas qu'il y a
beaucoup de monde qui vont aller faire
une demande d'injonction devant les
tribunaux pour qu'elle soit respectée la
Constitution je pense qu'il y a un
risque pour laque et le parti libérale à
Québec que d'avoir l'air intransigeant
sur cette question et finalement de
faire un petit peu comme ce que
Sébastien disait de donner beaucoup de
de crédibilité au pauvres aux pauvres
pékistes pas aux solidaire qui seront
expulsés
Parlement là on aurait le pays puis
Québec solidaire
de Marie-Claude Nikos qui a réagi
aujourd'hui qui a refusé la main tendue
de Dominique Anglade qu'il a expulsé la
semaine dernière bon Sébastien est-ce
que Dominique Anglade va pouvoir
demeurer chef du Parti libéral longtemps
à votre avis il y a de moins en moins de
gens qui pensent que oui d'ailleurs vous
aurez remarqué qu'il y a pas beaucoup de
gens qui viennent à la défense de
Dominique Anglade sur la place publique
je pense que on compte sur un doigt
d'une seule main c'est Carlos hier à
24,60 qui s'est lancé à la défense de
Madame Anglade donc elle est de plus en
plus isolée sont cocus reste quand même
derrière elle jusqu'à preuve du
contraire faut comprendre la dynamique
de ce focus il y en a 10 qui sont
nouveaux alors eux ils arrivent avec des
yeux gros comme des deux puis ça a pas
trop ce qui se passe en ce moment parce
qu'ils sont nouveaux dans la dans la
joute politique dans la dynamique
politique puis il y a ceux qui siaient à
la dernière législature qui craignent
probablement l'éclatement du parti et
l'éclatement du caucus donc ça fait une
drôle de dynamique et d'autres tout ça
Dominique Anglade semble vouloir rester
c'est à dire que même dans sa réaction
en fait que Marie-Claude Nicole ne
veuille pas revenir au caucus il dit
nous allons regarder en avant la porte
reste ouverte mais nous allons
maintenant nous concentrer sur des
sujets importants pour les Québécois
donc elle donne aucun signal qu'elle va
abdiquer elle donne plutôt des signaux
qu'elle veut s'accrocher d'ailleurs elle
le disait sur ce plateau hier soir il y
a beaucoup de pression à l'interne c'est
vrai d'anciens député mais aussi à
l'interne c'est ce qui avait poussé
devenir Kangen à faire des sorties dans
les médias justement puis à lui offrir
sa m’étendue à Hélène oui et puis en
fait toute cette question tout ce
conflit d'abord entre madame Nicole et
Madame Anglade témoigne quand même d'une
certaine
rigidité de part et d'autre
pourquoi on en est arrivé là pour une
question aussi futile finalement de
l'attribution de notre rôle dans le
cabinet fantôme il y a quelque chose qui
témoigne d'une peut-être une incapacité
de leadership d'un côté et d'un
peut-être d'une aversion envers la chef
de l'autre et ou d'une rigidité là
madame Anglade déjà le fait de tendre la
main après coup puis dire je serai prête
à la réalité il a fallu qu'elle pile
beaucoup sur son orgueil pour faire ça
ça lui faisait ça la faisait paraître
avec un très mauvais sens politique un
très un manque de leadership apparent et
que Madame ne cause n'est pas saisi
cette main tendue témoigne que elle a
peut-être pas vraiment envie de réparer
les ponts écoutez moi j'ai jamais
entendu parler d'un chef qui devant
autant de tourmente annonce qu'elle va
partir d'habitude on dit qu'on va rester
jusqu'à la dernière minute ça annonce
effectivement pas très bien pour la chef
libérale mais moi je le répète depuis
longtemps déjà si les libéraux la partie
libérale du Québec pense faire
l'économie d'un débat profond sur ce
qu'il incarne ce qu'il défend en se
débarrassant tout simplement de sa chef
et ben il fera erreur le problème du
Parti libéral c'est pas Dominique
Anglade c'est le parti libéral bon là
maintenant le prochain congrès c'est en
novembre 2023 si j'ai bien compris donc
dans un an d'ici novembre 2023 d'ici
novembre 2023 d'accord alors Christian
va de confiance pour devenir anglais
en fait jusqu'au moment où elle voit
démissionner c'est clair qu'elle va dire
que le démissionne pas c'est la règle du
jeu madame mexical tellement été
virulente c'est incroyable d'ordinaire
lorsque il y a une élection où il y a
des parties qui sont qui subissent des
échecs bon ça prend un certain temps
avant qu'on montre la sortie au chef
mais moi ça me fait penser je pense
qu'il y a une Rouchy au moment donné que
ça avait été très très vite parce que ça
semble pas la femme de la situation
surtout que le défi est énorme et puis
là se manifeste manifestement le montre
manifestement pas des cavités de
leadership qui sera à même de
trois mètres là mais c'est c'est un cas
de figure en fait
gouverner finalement dans les prochaines
semaines prochain mois avec son parti en
terminant je vais vous parler
d'immigration il reste trois petites
minutes donc taux de table les cibles
qui ont été annoncées aujourd'hui par le
ministre de l'Immigration 500 000
nouveaux arrivants par année pour le
pays Hélène qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
ces nouvelles sites du gouvernement
fédéral c'est très important de le
mentionner parce que en fait on avait
déjà les sites pour les deux premières
années et ils sont venus réinsérer donc
déjà c'est il y a toujours une
augmentation annuelle et là ils ont
décidé d'augmenter et en fait il y a
quelque chose de très dogmatique dans
cette décision parce que 500 000
personnes par année vous savez au Canada
la capacité de construction des nouveaux
logements et de moins de 300 000 par
année on n'est pas capable de construire
suffisamment de logements on espère
porter ça 400 000 et on se dit les
études indiquent qu'on n'a pas la main
d'oeuvre pour ça alors la question
très important mais ce qui est aussi
important c'est la protection du
français donc il y a une affrontement
direct entre les deux sur les sites
d'immigration et ça fait ça met une
pression sur le gouvernement du Québec
pour acquérir plus d'immigrants mais on
va vouloir résister à cette pression oui
sur la francisation également à plus
d'immigrants ça pourrait mettre en péril
le français c'est ce que mentionne le
gouvernement le goût Christian a terminé
c'est le dossier où je trouve le Québec
est le plus loin du reste du Canada bon
dans le reste du Canada on est confronté
entre autres à une idéologie
multiculturelle littéralement délirante
c'est comme si la caractéristique du
Canada dans le monde c'est d'accueillir
le plus d'immigrants possibles plus le
plus le plus et il y a un seul fichier
là-dedans parce que là il y a une partie
très importante de la population du
Canada qui est dessus de l'immigration
donc à ce moment-là on est encore plus
ouvert dans l'immigration donc c'est
clair que je crois que c'est le problème
numéro 1 du Québec au sein du Canada
parce que un incompatible biscuit on
peut incompatibilité assez fondamentale
en tout ce qu'on est nous les Québécois
là le peuple fondateur la nation
francophone puis est-ce ce pays là qui
est dans le délire moi je trouve c'est
du délire Hélène vous êtes qui et
Sébastien va bien merci beaucoup d'avoir
été là c'est panel bonne soirée au
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI